it just came out when you tell me not to
swear they just pop up
let's recipe the shop hey guys i'm abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
it is officially PSL season folks and
that means it's time to put on our basic
[ __ ] hats and March our way to
Starbucks but if you're feeling like
something a little more satisfying I
thought we would take the pumpkin spice
add as a latte and put it into three of
my favorite nourishing breakfast so I
have three awesome vegan and gluten free
morning recipes that you are going to
love let's do this first up bye pumpkin
spice oatmeal - a saucepot I add some
unsweetened vanilla almond milk and some
rolled oats and I bring it to a boil
then I reduce it to simmer and add in
some pumpkin puree mince dates pumpkin
pie spice vanilla extract and some ripe
match banana and I cook that until it
all comes together and cooks through top
it off with some pecans and spice
pepitas and enjoy next my pumpkin
protein smoothie Bowl - food processor I
on some coconut yogurt frozen banana
pumpkin puree vegan vanilla protein
powder pumpkin pie spice and some
unsweetened almond milk and I carry that
until it gets nice and smooth
top it off with some fresh apples some
freeze-dried apples some pecans
peppiness
and some hemp hearts dig in and enjoy
finally my pumping chia pudding
the food processor I add some unspin
mill on milk coconut yogurt chia seeds
pumpkin puree some mid states
you know extract & Fitch's films and I
carry that until it's really nice and
smooth refrigerate that for at least an
hour then I layer into my parfait dish
with some coconut whipped cream top with
some pumpkin pie spice some pecans and
pepitas sorry decaf ristretto almond
milk pumpkin spice latte extra foam
extra hot oh I don't need you anymore
because I have these three awesome
pumpkin spice recipes and I'm so excited
for you guys to try them out if you love
these recipes be sure to give me a
thumbs up leave me a comment below some
of your favorite pumpkin inspired
recipes and also I want to know your
coffee orders subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen bye
[Music]